aujourd'hui c'est l'Europe naturiste qui
est réuni à tout mais ce qu'on éprouve
un plaisir particulier à nager comme
cela ah il est certain que tant qu'il y
en a pas essayé on ne peut pas se rendre
compte mais je dirais comme beaucoup de
slogans l'essayer c'est l'adopter
lorsque l'on a nagé une fois nu on a
vraiment pu envie de remettre un
vêtement et sur le plan technique il
présente que ça il paraît que ça
présente des avantages je pense qu'il
est exact de nager nu permet de
meilleures performances puisque au cours
d'une rencontre internationale de
natation qui n'était pas naturiste
certains des nageurs participants des
terres rasés
je précise la tête c'est un problème de
glisse
vraisemblablement c'est un problème de
Nice mais il y a tout de même quelques
petits obstacles quand on a fini rien je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait des obstacles
je pense que le corps est en tal
horizontal il y en a mais vous pensez à
jour introduire ce discipline de jeux
olympiques et bien nous n'avons pas
évidemment la prétention d'organiser des
Olympiades naturistes du même niveau que
les Jeux Olympiques actuels mais
néanmoins cela permettrait à ceux qui ne
connaît pas qui ne connaissent pas de
naturisme de mieux le connaître
justement pourquoi demander la lune une
fois pas demander la lune
[Musique]